-Let's get to the news.
President Biden made a surprise
trip last week to Ukraine
by taking a 10-hour train ride,
or as the guy next to him
thought,
an 80-hour train ride.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden reportedly
had a difficult time sleeping
last week on the overnight train
ride from Poland to Ukraine
and read a briefing memo
on the history of Kyiv,
and that didn't
put him to sleep?
That would have
put the last president
into a multi-year coma.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
President Biden said
that he has
"other things to finish
before launching a full-blown
presidential campaign."
Like, for instance,
"Yellowstone."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
then-President Trump
was so upset with "Late Night"
host Jimmy Kimmel's criticism
that he asked
White House staffers
to call Disney executives.
And he was apparently so upset
with me that he called my boss.
-That's right, Seth,
and I told him to get lost.
[ Laughter ]
-Good looking out, Wally.
Thank you.
-You're welcome. Yep.
-Vice President Kamala Harris
spoke today in South Carolina
about the Biden
administration's expansion
of high-speed Internet access.
Although, it didn't help matters
that the live stream
started like this.
[ Modem dialing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Dialing stops ]
An-n-n-nd we're live.
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans reportedly
planning to hold hearings
on the Biden administration's
response
to the toxic train wreck
in East Palestine, Ohio.
And one way or another,
they're going to figure out
how Hunter Biden
sabotaged that train.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis'
book "The Courage to be Free"
is set to be released tomorrow.
Look for it
wherever books are legal.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
held a three-day retreat
over the weekend for top donors
and supporters
at the Four Seasons
in Palm Beach.
For a $10,000 donation,
you got to meet him.
And for $20,000, you didn't.
[ Laughter ]
An alligator
was recently captured
in Brooklyn's Prospect Park
and taken to the Bronx Zoo.
You made it move from Brooklyn
to the Bronx?
[ Laughter ]
At least try turn it into boots
and let it die with dignity.
[ Laughter ]
Firefighters in North Carolina
recently rescued
a newlywed couple
that got stuck
in an elevator for 2.5 hours
after their wedding.
The couple is doing fine
and ready to get on
with their divorce.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman in Georgia
was arrested last week
after she allegedly drove her
car into a Popeyes restaurant
because her order
did not have biscuits.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, those biscuits
are the only thing that
take the edge off the meth.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden held an event
yesterday at the White House
celebrating Black History Month.
Also being held at
the White House,
everyone's breath.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right.
President Biden held an event
yesterday at the White House
celebrating Black History Month.
Man, how many times do you
think he casually
mentioned knowing Obama?
[ Laughter ]
"So I was talking to Barry
the other day --
sorry, Barack -- Obama,
former co-worker."
[ Laughter ]
When asked in a new interview
if he's planning on running
for re-election in 2024,
President Biden joked that
he needed to call First Lady
Dr. Jill Biden to "find out."
Okay, but you know she's not
that kind of doctor, right?
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
signed a bill into law yesterday
that takes away Disney World's
self-governing status.
So, if you're at Disney --
[ Audience boos ]
If you're at Disney,
I have even more bad news.
Now you're also in Florida.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene said
in a Twitter post last night
that she was attacked
by an insane woman
inside a restaurant.
Luckily the incident was
resolved after the restaurant
took the mirror down.
[ Laughter ]
"That's my outfit."
According to a new poll,
66% of New York voters believe
that Republican Congressman
George Santos should step down,
while the other 34% believe
anything apparently.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Minnesota
recently arrested a man
on suspicion of drunk driving
after he allegedly fell
asleep in an Arby's
drive-through.
It's the rare occasion
where drunk driving
may have saved someone's life.
[ Laughter ]
A Chinese company has begun
offering a device that simulates
kissing using a set
of silicon lips
controlled by an app.
Yeah...
[ Laughter ]
That's what it will be used for.
"I'm going to sell this to you.
Kissing only, alright, man?"
"Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I love kissing."
[ Laughter ]
And -- [ Laughs ]
And finally, a man in California
recently broke
the Guinness world record
for most consecutive visits
to Disneyland after visiting
the park nearly 3,000 times.
Even crazier, this guy's been
to SeaWorld twice.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden kicked off
House Democrats' 3-day retreat
tonight
with a speech in Baltimore.
Well, it was supposed to be
a one-day retreat,
but when that guy gets
talking...
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
said this week
that federal agencies will
have to remove TikTok
from all government devices
in 30 days,
and if they're smart, Venmo.
Matt?
[ Laughter ]
In a post yesterday
on Truth Social,
Former President Trump accused
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
of wanting to cut
Social Security and Medicare,
and said he was a "wheelchair
over the cliff" kind of guy.
As opposed to Trump, who would
never waste a perfectly good
wheelchair.
[ Laughter ]
Mexican President Lopez Obrador
pushed back against criticism
yesterday of his recent
electoral reforms and said,
"There is more democracy
in Mexico
than could exist in
the United States."
Well, that's not the high bar
it used to be.
[ Laughter ]
That's like me saying I'm
a better tennis player
than Richard Kind,
who's backstage,
and we're gonna find out
when he comes out
if he thinks he can
beat me in tennis,
'cause I bet he probably could.
During oral arguments yesterday
in a case challenging
President Biden's student debt
forgiveness plan,
Supreme Court Justice
Neil Gorsuch
said the program was unfair
and failed to take into account
people who had paid off
their loans or never had them.
Yeah, can someone for once
think of the people
who never had student loans?
When do they get a break?
That's like saying no Tinder,
it's not fair to the people
who already get laid.
[ Laughter ]
Television provider Dish Network
confirmed yesterday
that a previous outage
was caused by
a cybersecurity breach,
and not, as customers assumed,
by a gentle rain.
[ Laughter ]
Dictionary.com yesterday
unveiled new entries,
including the word "woke."
"Still not gonna look it up!"
said Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida woman was arrested
last week
after she told deputies
during a traffic stop
she had drugs in
her body cavity,
and removed nearly 11 grams
of crystal meth.
Said the cops,
"Ma'am, we pulled you over
for a broken tail light."
[ Laughter ]
"Still, pretty impressive,
though, officers."
Fast food chain KFC
today announced
the return of the Double Down,
a bun-free sandwich
that substitutes bread
with chicken,
so you can substitute
hunger with self-loathing.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the pharmaceutical
company Eli Lilly
announced today that it will cap
the out-of-pocket cost
of insulin at $35 --
and not a moment too soon.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
Georgia Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene yesterday,
and suggested that her politics
are causing Republicans
to join the Democratic Party.
Oh, come on,
we can't even get Democrats
to join the Democratic Party.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
68% of voters said that
President Biden is too old
for another term.
I don't know. I mean, okay,
he's an 80-year-old man.
But the job is mostly
telling long stories
that don't go anywhere...
[ Laughter ]
...signing whatever
a young person hands you...
and arguing with foreigners
and drug companies.
Man for the job, I say.
The House Foreign Affairs
committee voted yesterday
to advance a bill
that would allow
President Biden to ban TikTok.
Ban it? He hasn't even
figured out how to download it.
[ Laughter ]
"Hello,
TikTok customer service?"
[ Light laughter ]
A spokesperson for
the Chinese Foreign Ministry
said today that the U.S.
should cease weapon sales
and military contact
with Taiwan.
Oh, what are you going to do,
send another balloon?
I'd like to see you try!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, damn, that was fast, wow.
It's right outside.
Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders
recently released a new book
titled "It's OK to be Angry
About Capitalism."
And if you still don't believe
him, you can look at the price.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Bernie Sanders recently
released a new book titled
"It's OK to be Angry About
Capitalism."
And if you like that, check out
the rest of the books in his
"It's OK to be Angry"
collection.
[ Laughter ]
The Supreme Court
heard arguments yesterday
in a dispute between
New York and New Jersey.
It was the case of "ayy!"
versus "ohhh!"
[ Laughter ]
A very subtle...
very subtle but real difference.
[ Light laughter ]
"The New York Times"
published a profile yesterday
of a man who has
lived his life mostly barefoot
for the past 20 years.
And bad news,
he's on your flight.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have announced
that actress Bebe Neuwirth
will return for the revival
of the sitcom "Frasier"
to repr-- to reprise --
excuse me --
her role as Lilith Sternin.
Not returning, Eddie the dog.
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah, you guys thought you
didn't like that barefoot joke.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't realize that --
those were the heights.
[ Light laughter ]
Officials at a zoo in Nebraska
this week
confirmed that a cheetah briefly
escaped from its enclosure.
Oh, good, only briefly.
It's just a cheetah.
How far could it have gotten?
[ Laughter ]
It was chasing Eddie.
[ Light laughter ]
According to a new survey,
the Tooth Fairy now leaves
more than $6 per tooth
on average,
which explains
the recent increase
in 7-year-olds
taking up hockey.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a cruise line
is now accepting reservations
for the first ever
three-year-long cruise,
two years with good behavior.
And...
that was the monologue,
everybody!
♪♪